hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over
the hyper accelerated dragon in the
sicilian defense so the sicilian starts
out with e4
c5 this is the sicilian and then after
knight to f3
black plays g6 now before we get into
the hyper-accelerated dragon
it's good to understand both the dragon
and the accelerated
dragon i do have a video on both of
those i recommend at some point you
watch those if you're gonna play any of
the dragon systems first we're going to
take a look at the main line in
the dragon and that starts out with d6
instead of that g6 move here and d6 is
one of the main differences
in the dragon as well as the accelerated
and the hyper accelerated
because this d6 pawn is protecting
the e5 square which usually in the other
variations you're going to be using your
knight here on
c6 to protect the square here on
e5 but in the dragon black normally
plays d6
and then we see d4 there's an exchange
in the center of the board
knight to f6 and then after knight to c3
we play g6 this is
the dragon now one reason that players
will not opt to play the dragon is
because this is a
very aggressive line one of the sharpest
variations in all the sicilian which is
already a very
sharp defense from black and
one of the most aggressive lines is the
yugoslav attack which continues with
bishop to e3
bishop to g7 fiance on the king side
f3 here and after castle on the king
side we have queen two d2
knight c6 and then castle on the queen
side
both sides castling on opposite sides
and it really comes down to throwing all
your material
at your opponent sacking up a bunch of
material
and then hopefully win a quick checkmate
in these types of games
every single move matters and so what
black has found over time
is that controlling the center of the
board in the types of games is very
important
and black would really like to play the
move d5
at some point but black has already used
one of its moves to play this
d7 to d6 so the other variations we're
going to look at
the accelerated and then the main video
the hyper accelerated
really dig into what if black doesn't
play this move here
of d6 now if we come back to this
position the
main difference in the accelerated and
even the hyper-accelerated compared to
the dragon
is this d-pawn right here the dragon
pushes it to d6
but the other variations black's looking
to play the move d5
at some point not early on and so
instead of playing d6
black plays knight to c6 this is the
accelerated dragon
and this piece is defending the square
here on
e5 now after d4 exchange here
knight takes on d4 then pawn to g6
so the in the accelerated dragon black
is able to avoid the most aggressive
line that white has and that's the
yugoslav attack
but white also has compensation white's
able to play the move
pawn to c4 because the knight is not
blocking the pawn which many times in
the sicilian
you do have the knight here on c3 so you
can't push forward with that pawn
so pawn to c4 and this is the
moroxy bind it's very difficult for
black many times to combat this because
as we mentioned earlier one of the key
moves that black's looking to do
is play d5 white now has
two pawns controlling
this square right here on d5
so that's kind of main ideas in the
dragon in the accelerated dragon so now
we're going to get into
the hyper accelerated dragon and the
hyper accelerated dragon instead of
playing
d6 or knight to c6 black plays the move
g6 now because this e5 square is
undefended
that means that black is looking to play
bishop to g7
before black ever plays the move knight
to
f6 so in this video today we're going to
be looking at a few options
but they're all going to come from the
move d4 this is the main line that
you're going to see
and so after the exchange right here
we're going to look at one
if they take here on d4 if they do
black's always playing bishop here to g7
and they have two main options that
you'll see one is if they continue with
the main line of knight to c3
the others if they play the meroxy bind
in this position and that is
with pawn to c4 those are the most
common ones that you'll see
the other variation we are going to look
at is if what if the knight doesn't take
here on d4 what if the queen takes here
on
d4 which is a reasonable play get a very
powerful piece involved into the center
of the board it just opened up
this diagonal right here in this case
you throw everything out the window you
can't play that bishop here to g7
you have to play the knight to f6
knowing that they can now push forward
here to e5 so those are the variations
we are going to look at there are a lot
of variations
in the hyper-accelerated dragon if you
want to see others
feel free to let me know in the comments
if this is a very popular video and you
do
like to see extended lines in the
sicilian happy to make another video
on this variation or
any of the other dragon variations as
well
the first variation we are going to look
at is after d4
we do see the exchange right here knight
takes on d4
and then bishop to g7 white has two
options
knight to c3 and the pawn c4 we're going
to be looking at knight to c3
first and black's going to play knight
to
c6 now pretty much any high level player
is never going to take
with their knight here on c6 it's a bad
move
don't do that black can recapture with
the b-pawn
now black has more central pawns also
opens up the door for the light square
bishop to get involved into the game
and the rook can easily come here to the
b file it's a semi-open
file for this rook to attack as we
already mentioned in this variation
white many times is looking to castle on
the queen side if you have a rook here
on the b
file eyeing down on the queen side
that's not a very good thing
for white so they really should not be
looking to exchange but if they do
you can punish them it's definitely not
something that white should
look to do so if they do play knight to
c6
which you're going to be playing bishop
and the knight both eyeing down this
knight right here
white should be playing bishop to e3
this is the most common
for sure that you're gonna see because
they're looking to develop their queen
type pieces
so they can castle to the queen side of
the board now black plays knight to
f6 preparing to castle on the king side
you have bishop down here to
c4 and then you have a couple options as
far as
how black can continue one option i'd
consider it more the safe option is just
to castle
on the king side from here they can
bring their bishop back to
b3 remember at some point in the hyper
accelerated dragon black is looking to
push forward with
d5 and this makes sure
that it's kind of out of the way of that
thread at some point black can be
looking to play knight takes here on e4
and then follow that up at some point
with d5
opening up for the light square bishop
also to get involved into the game so
bishop to b3 makes a lot of sense at
this point you could play queen to
a5 pinning down the knight on c3 to the
king
but if we come back i think an even
better line to play in this position
instead of castling on the king side
right away
is to play that queen to
a5 this is pinning down the knights
right away and you can see the threat
this knight is the only defender of
this e4 square so the threat is
knight taking here on e4
now if we start to look at how white can
really defend this well
one you could try to defend it by
playing queen to
d3 forget the fact that the knights
pinned you just want to protect this
pawn right here on e4 unfortunately
this isn't going to work out too well
because black just has to move knight to
e5 this is attacking the queen the queen
is forced to move
it can no longer defend this pawn and
then knight takes here on e4
that's not a very good alternative for
white so instead they could play
queen to d2 then things get pretty crazy
because black can still take there on e4
now there could be an exchange knight
takes here on a c6 attacking
the queen you can see the queen take
here
you could see an exchange on board but
all of a sudden white has double pawns
now white does have the bishop pair here
but at the end of the day i like this
position
from black for sure the pawn structure
is just much better and black should be
able to
turn this into a win so they usually are
not going to be
using their queen to stop this pin right
here instead they should just be looking
to castle on
the king side if that's the case black
can also just castle on
the king side as well and now there's
lots of options you could see
a3 from white you could see the bishop
come back to b3 you can even play the
knight here too b3 attacking the queen
but the queen here on a5 has lots of
options as well it can swing over to the
king side of the board
now this is a little bit different than
kind of your normal dragon lines where
white's castling on the queen side but
this move queen to a5 really forced
their hand as we come back and look at
the
king castling you really want to be
moving your queen
in the normal dragon line so that you
can castle queenside but we already
looked it doesn't do a lot of good if
white
moves this queen and then looks to
castle on the queen side so uh it's not
as aggressive as the normal dragon lines
which is one of the reason that some
people like to play the
hyper-accelerated dragon
now let's take a look at the moroxy bind
variation in the
hyper-accelerated dragon and so instead
of knight to c3 white's gonna be playing
pawn to
c4 trying to stop the push for the black
has
of pawn to d5 at some point so black
can't play that right away
instead knight to c6 attacking the
knight here on d4 we've already talked
about white should not be looking to
take this material right here
they could but they probably won't
instead since the knight and the bishop
are both attacking
then just reinforce right here with
bishop to e3
these are the most common lines that you
will see if you don't
there's probably a theory around a
much better position that black's going
to get out of this
knight 2 f 6 this square here on e5
can't push forward because this knight
here on c6 so very different than the
dragon as we talked about which
normally protects that e5 square with d6
now knight two c3 now a very
interesting move from black and that's
the move knight to
g4 attacking this bishop here on
e3 and really the best move from white
is to take with
the queen here on g4 and it looks weird
like this knight here on
g4 is not protected if the pawn had
already pushed forward that makes sense
the bishop here on the c8 is protecting
that
but it's not protected right now the
queen can just take it
right away but this is okay because
black has the move knight takes here on
d4 but there's no other options really
that white has here
if the bishop moves okay well then
there's only one defender on this knight
here on d4 both the knight and the
bishop are attacking it
so it's either going to fall or
you're going to see it move and this
knight here on d4 is not going to be
protected so
queen takes here on a g4 knight takes
here on
d4 and then there's a few options really
the threat here
is that this knight here on d4
is threatening to come here on a c2
check
and fork this rook here on a1
so i just showed one of the moves here
one of the options is to play queen to
d1 we have to think about how white can
protect the square here on
c2 another option is to castle on the
king side or
they could play bishop here to d3 so
let's look at that first option there of
castling on
the kings or the queen side i think this
is a good option from white it gets a
rook
engaged into the game but you can see
there's a lot of air in front of this
king so there's a lot of exposure that
black can start to attack at some point
because there's no pawns in front of it
at all even if it comes over here to b1
it's still very vulnerable to an attack
but right away this does
force the knight to come back here to c6
now if they use the bishop instead so
bishop here to d3 this is protecting
this
c2 square well now black can play the
move
d5 and the reason they can play that you
may look at and say well man
before he said you couldn't play d5
because both of these pawns are right
here the difference is this is a
discovered attack on
the queen so part of getting the queen
out here to g4
is so that black can attack with a
discovered attack so this is opening up
a lot of attacking lines
that black has in there so they may look
at this and say well i don't want that
discovered attack on my queen so what if
i just bring my queen back here to d1
they can absolutely do this and this is
i think
fine for white it protects the c2 square
as they need to do from the fork here
but also keeps it so black can't just
push forward that easily
with d5 with a discovered attack now
black
instead of d5 is now going to be looking
to play the move
e5 this is a great outpost for this
knight here on
d4 and this is just adding another layer
of protection
for the knight here on d4
now because the pawn is here on e5
black's not going to be looking to push
forward here on
d5 that ship is sail they're looking to
now support
these dark squares so they may be
looking to play
d6 at some point that makes sense this
opens up for the light square bishop to
get involved
supports this pawn here on e5 so d6 is a
viable option
castling on the king side not going to
be doing that on the queen side
but this is how you're going to be
playing it if you go against the meroxie
bind
in the hyper-accelerated dragon the last
variation we're going to go over is what
if the knight doesn't take care on d4
what if the queen just takes
here on d4 attacking this rook here on a
chase
black can't play bishop to g7 is forced
to play
knight to f6 but as you can tell
from the other examples knight to f6
without
a d6 or a knight on c6
means that white can play the move pawn
to e5
now luckily that although the knights
attacked
black doesn't have to respond to this
threat right away because black has the
move knight to
c6 attacking this queen here on d4 now
there's kind of
two options that you'll see here one is
if
the queen comes over here and is not
defending
or attacking the square here on d5
because then black can just play knight
to d5 and then play bishop here to g7
castle on the king side and things are
fine this is a good position
for black if they try to maintain
control of the d5 square so maybe
queen to c4 well now you're first going
to be playing
the move d5 this opens up for the light
square bishop to get involved into the
game you also want to be
attacking uh this material from
the queen so that's that's definitely
one option here
if they on poisson so they can actually
capture they have one move and one move
only to capture this material
then black can play the move bishop to
e6 they can also just capture with their
queen but i like attacking in this
position so bishop here to
e6 forcing the queen to move then they
can play bishop here to g7
castle on the king side get your rook
over here to
the d file i can even bring it to the c
file as well depending on how
they've set up their board now if we
come back they don't have to play
e5 pushing forward they could just
continue with
you know a normal knight to c3
building from the kind of the main lines
of
the sicilian from white standpoint from
here
black's still going to be pushing with
knight to c6 attacking the queen here
queen's forced to move and similar as we
talked about before there's a couple
options but if they play
queen to a4 well now we're going to be
playing
this move d6 because
we do need to stop the threat of e5
now that's usually done by d6 or
c6 but this queen over here is
sort of annoying and we need to be
moving one of our pawns in the center of
the board
and so eventually we want to be moving
our d-pawn
but we also know that we can't just push
forward here with d5 they can push
forward on e5
and then our knights pin down that's not
a good position from us as well so
while you're normally not playing d6 in
the hyper accelerated dragon
this is a completely different setup
because the queen took here on
d4 now once they're taking with their
knights
in those variations you're usually going
to be looking to play d7 to d5
but if they capture with their queen
just know it's completely out the window
and you are going to be looking to play
d6 if they're playing that queen to
a5 so these are just some of the main
variations that you will see
as you can imagine there's a lot of
variations in the hyper-accelerated
dragon
uh definitely a good one though i
recommend watching the others if you
haven't already the main dragon as well
as the accelerated dragon
i'm curious though for those who have
watched the entire video
uh let me know in the comments below and
just put a hundred
after your comment that'll let me know
that you've watched the
entire video i know some people don't
get through the whole thing
but curious if you did make the entire
thing also just curious feedback on
this setup this is the first video where
i've done commentary where i'm on camera
so trying it out let me know what you
think there's things that
could be improved if you like the layout
that i have going on
all that feedback is just going to let
me make better and better videos
in the future so thank you guys so much
for watching if there's
other variations in the sicilian and the
hyper-accelerated dragon that you want
to see feel free to let me know
in the comments below you can also email
me as well but thanks so much for
watching
i'll see you on the next video